(upbeat music)
- It's in our genes.
It's in our blood.
Everything that's needed
in rugby is sort of
incorporated in a Fijian when he's born.
People still can't
believe that Fijians are
really, really good at rugby.
(upbeat music)
- My name is David Dakuitoga,
and I'm the founder of Yamacia Rugby Club.
Yamacia rugby is an initiative
to give a second chance
to unemployed youths,
and minimize the drug use
around the province of Namosi.
Rugby would be one thing that
will take their mind away
from doing all those things,
and get them to do something
positive in their lives.
We have limited resources.
We train using what we have.
We use logs,
we use tires,
we use anything and everything.
What we do makes us
stronger and sort of tougher
because guys get to work
even harder than the guys
with those modern resources.
What we are trying to
achieve is to get boys into
the wider world of rugby.
We've played tournaments in Fiji, Samoa,
Australia, and Paris, and Europe as well.
When one of my club members get a contract
and play in a tournament,
my whole body it's just so excited.
My heart it's just full of joy.
Oh, my goodness, it's just so good,
feels so good.
Rugby has changed my life in a way that
now I'm able to provide
opportunities to other people.
I can give back to Fiji as a whole.
So, rugby is a life changer.